This tulip photograph,
taken with a low-end camera,
exhibits a grayish look.
We first manipulate its
large-scale component
to increase overall contrast.
Note that this manipulation
only alters the tonal balance
while the amount of
texture remains the same.
We can independently control
the amount of detail.
This manipulation
preserves the tonal balance
that we just created.
We can also provide a model
image such as this masterpiece
by Ansel Adams, and the
system automatically
transfers its multi-scale
characteristics.
In comparison, a simple
pixel histogram matching
does not achieve the
appropriate texture level.
The user can still
control the parameters
to finely tune the rendition.
Finally, the user can browse
previous working sessions
and predefined settings to
quickly explore various styles.
To better appreciate
our results,
we encourage you to consult
the prints in the accompanying
portfolio.